Well,
I think this person does exist,
but it's really confined primarily to
the opposition party,
to the supporters of the opposition
party.
Um,
and we saw the same thing really,
um,
during the Bush administration,
uh,
particularly the last two years of the
Bush administration.
There were a lot of angry voters out
there,
but the,
at that time,
they were,
they were almost all democrats who were
upset about things like the war in Iraq,
uh,
about,
um,
Bush administration's,
you know,
economic and environmental policies and
so on.
Now with a Democratic president and
Congress,
it's the Republicans,
uh,
especially the more engaged Republicans
who are angry.
They're angry because they disagree,
you know,
with the Democrats on issues like
healthcare,
uh,
and budgetary priorities and so on.
So,
yes,
I mean,
I think there are angry voters that they
there.
I think sometimes it gets a little
overblown,
you know,
because I'm not sure that,
um,
voters are really angry or overall now
than they have been in the past.
Um,
I think it's just that we're seeing more
visible manifestations of that with
these tea party demonstrations.
Well,
they're not angry anymore because now,
uh,
for the most part pick because you have
a democratic president.
Um,
now they,
um,
some of them might still not be thrilled
with all of the things the Obama
administration has done.
But by and large,
I think what you find is that there's
been a reversal,
you know,
that,
uh,
you know,
sort of like the,
the anger is gone over from one side to
the,
to the other,
not right now,
you know,
because again,
it's harder I think for people to get
worked up when,
you know,
they're in the majority,
um,
that especially in midterm elections,
we tend to see that it's the disgruntled
people who are the most active.
We saw that in 2006 where it was really
the Democrats by and large,
who are the most enthusiastic,
most engaged.
Um,
and now it's,
uh,
the Republicans,
you know,
with a Democrat in the White House.
Uh,
so it's sort of part of the normal cycle
of American politics.
That's what tends to happen in these,
in these midterm elections.
It's just that with increasing
polarization,
you know,
I think what happens now is that these
swings become greater,
um,
and the reaction becomes even stronger.
Okay.